hello believe nation today I'm going to
talk about the 7 things you must do to
achieve your goals so one of the things
I find with a lot of entrepreneurs is we
set goals right we have goals upon goals
upon goals we have to-do lists a mile
high and we just keep setting goals and
we don't necessarily actually follow
through or achieve them and so today I'm
going to share with you my seven ways to
actually get your goals accomplished
[Music]
number one is set the right goals this
is really important a lot of times we
don't set the right goals for us we set
the goals that we think we should do
where the other people want for us but
not the ones that are actually right for
us I think of an example when I was
listening to an audio book on goal
setting and the speaker was talking
about in a really passionate manner
write down all your goals if you want to
be a painter
write down create a masterpiece if you
want to make a sculpture write that down
create a sculpture you want to write a
score for a song write that down and I
go wow that sounds so interesting like I
want to do that I want to be I want to
paint something why not I want to make a
sculpture yeah it's awesome I'm gonna
come back to and I realize you know what
like I don't actually want to make a
sculpture I got kind of wrapped up in
the moment listening to the excitement
of this speaker but it wasn't something
I've actually really deep down wanted to
do and so you really want to make sure
that the goals you set for yourself are
ones that even when you come back to a
week later a month later still resonate
with you like the goal has to mean
something if you don't care about the
goal and actually accomplishing it or if
you're doing it just for somebody else
and it doesn't really mean something to
you then you're never gonna follow
through so I'd really forced you to
audit your goals and look at them and
examine them and think do these actually
excite me do I have the right goals that
I want to build around and then you can
focus on worrying about the steps to
achieve them
[Music]
number two is have an important why and
this aligns closely with the first one
why is this so important why is it so
important that you go out and accomplish
that goal it has to come from a deep
reason that really resonates with you
otherwise it's just gonna be a wish list
and we all have a wish list
we all have again that to-do list that's
a mile high and the ones that you
actually deeply meaningfully care about
you have a strong Y attached to it those
are the ones that you're gonna do too
often though we only do the things that
we're forced to do you do it because a
customer is asking for it or you do it
because you know somebody in your family
is forcing me to do it you don't
actually do it because you have a deep
lie for it and so really important is
when you look at your goals attaching a
strong Y to each one if you can't figure
one out then drop the goal because
you're never gonna get it done it's just
gonna continue to be a wish list and we
want to move it from a wish list to
actually add lists the goals that we're
gonna accomplish
[Music]
number three is take daily action if
this is important to you that you
accomplish this goal then you have to
schedule it in deep look at your
calendar and schedule time for it to
happen daily it doesn't have to be a ton
of time doesn't mean that you now have
five hours a day to spend on this but
every day you need to take some kind of
action even if it's small at least half
an hour moving forward on your goal
especially if you're doing this
part-time you have a full-time job you
have a family to take care of get lots
of demands to your time you need to
carve out the time if you don't carve
out the time to accomplish your goals
the rest of your life will take over
what happened there's this theory of big
rocks first imagine you've got sand
you've got pebbles and you've got big
rocks if you put the sand in first and
then the pebbles and you put the big
rocks into a jar it won't all fit
together it's gonna overflow but if you
put the big rocks in first then the
pebbles will come in and will fit around
the big rocks and then the sand will
come in and fit around the pebbles and
they'll all fit into the jar that jar is
your schedule if you're constantly just
doing the little things which is the
sand and then the pebbles you never have
time to do the big things which are your
rocks but this is important to you then
you put the big rocks in first a justice
calendar adjust your schedule so that
the things that you want to
Cowboys that are on that goal list or in
your weekly calendar so that you're
doing something consistently on it and
then the rest of life will be the
pebbles insane and we'll find ways to
take up your time but you need to defend
that time in your calendar to work on
the important goals number four is
commit to somebody else you're way more
likely to follow through on something
when you commit to somebody else when
you tell a friend family member a
colleague that you are going to do
something you're much more likely to do
it you know I told Jason I'm gonna be
here at 8:30 in the morning to film this
video I showed up here at 8:30 in the
morning when you don't commit to
somebody else when it's just you
committing to yourself you're really
likely to let yourself down we are not
great accountability partners for
ourselves we will let ourselves down
constantly and so when you can commit to
somebody else your chances of achieving
your goal go up dramatically so you can
do it through a buddy system you know
maybe you have a spouse you want to do
this with maybe you have a friend that
you want to do this with maybe there's
somebody else in your industry that you
want to do this with where you have your
monthly goals or weekly goals and you
connect me do it through a mastermind
group it's what I do for myself we've
got eight people in a mastermind group
and we meet physically once per month to
talk about our goals and then every
member is partnered up with somebody
else
in the group and every week you have a
phone call with them it could be just 10
15 minute phone call once a week to make
sure that you do the things that you say
you're going to do so here's what I want
to get done before our meeting next
month and then you have a weekly call to
say how you're making forward progress
on it or not and what you hate doing is
reporting to your partner that you
didn't do it and so having that weekly
accountability helps make sure that
you're making forward progress and
sometimes that person needs to hold your
hand a little bit and sometimes that
person needs to light a fire under your
butt a little bit just depends on the
role depends where you're at but having
an accountability partner committing to
somebody else to say you're gonna do it
and having them hold your feet to the
fire a little bit helps make sure that
you're going to accomplish your goals
[Music]
number five is model success one of my
favorite things to do to accomplish any
goal is some model success I find
somebody who's already accomplished what
I want to do figure out what worked for
them and then try it in my business this
is what saved my first company at the
beginning I've had to do everything
myself I tried to come with every new
idea myself I thought I was a creative
person and I could solve this problem
and I could solve a lot of problems but
you know what's even faster is finding
somebody else has already solved it and
then just tweak their system and make it
work for you you know Starbucks was
started because Howard Schultz went to
Milan in Italy and saw how the coffee
shop was the center of life in Italy was
the third home between homework it was
the third meeting spot and he looked at
North America and he saw like the Dunkin
Donuts of the world where it's just in
and out you don't really spend any time
in a Dunkin Donuts
they said I want to bring this Italian
way of living to North America and then
later to the world and it worked like
all he did to build a multi-billion
dollar Empire one of the biggest brands
in the world was model what worked in a
different market and brought it to North
America whatever problem you're facing
right now at achieving your goal
somebody has already done it look to
them understand their success the bigger
they are the easier it is to find out
the early days right and that's what you
want to figure out how Howard Schultz
opens another Starbucks right now is not
interesting how we went from like zero
to one how did he build those first few
stores how did they make their first
million that is super interesting and so
that's what you need to model to help
you accomplish your goals
[Music]
number six is bring on a team as soon as
you can afford it you want to be able to
bring on a team to help you accomplish
your goal because the bigger the goal is
the more people are you going to need
and I think a lot of people have it in
their head that you need to hire
somebody full-time and that's gonna cost
X thousand dollars a year you don't the
first guy I hired for my business I
hired for one hour day and that saved me
more than one hour day of time because
he was better at doing the job than I
was and it freed up my time to go off
and do more important things help me
build my business so as soon as you're
starting to make any kind of money
doesn't be a lot of money anything I
would take a good portion of that and
invest it back into bringing on somebody
to help me even if it was for one hour a
day or a couple hours a week so you can
make forward momentum and forward
progress you can't do this alone you
can't if you have a big goal it's not
gonna happen with just you doing
everything and so the faster you can get
used to bringing on a team the better
and also as a side benefit helps build
up your leadership skills so that you're
getting used to managing the team
because you're gonna make a lot of
mistakes too if you've never managed
people before you're gonna make a ton of
mistakes and better that it happens on a
really small scale and you learn from it
and get better then if it really now
becomes important because you've hired
somebody full-time and it has to work
and number seven is enjoy the process
I've talked about this a lot on the
channel it has to be important to you
that it's not just about achieving the
goal but it's about enjoying the work on
the way to the goal it's super important
you can only force yourself to do
something for so long before you give up
and you quit like if you don't enjoy the
work of what you're doing and your only
goal is achieving that outcome you're
gonna fail you're gonna fail because you
don't enjoy the work with the successful
people who are high achievers and
achieve their goals they like the work
as well the goal is almost secondary to
the actual work like my goal to hit a
million YouTube subscribers is a good
goal it's the next kind of logical step
after hitting a hundred thousand great
like here's our goal but much more
important than hitting the million
subscribers is this is this getting
better was me enjoying the process of
filming and working on how do we get the
videos out there better and how do we
improve the whole experience for
everybody like that's what really really
really
ultimately drives me much more than just
hitting the 1 million because when we
hit a million it'll be a little Wayne
like great hey million we get a you know
new gold plaque whatever YouTube sends
you okay let's keep going right like I'm
not done like a million is nothing we
got to keep going keep building keep
helping entrepreneurs and so the process
is more important than the goal the goal
helps you align your process a little
bit better that's the goal you really
want to accomplish for me to hit a
million subscribers then I have to do
certain work I have to focus on bigger
picture things on my youtube channel and
continue to make improvements to get
better but that's the work that I love
doing and so make sure that you are
picking goals where you are not just
excited about the goal but you're
excited about the work that goes into
achieving the goal as well so those are
my suggestions for the 7 things you must
do to accomplish your goal I'd love to
know what do you think which one
resonated the most with you which ones
you need the most help with and did I
miss an 819 that you want to add to the
list help out believe nation show some
love leave it down in the comments below
super curious to see what you have to
say and we'll join in the discussion
thank you guys so much for watching I
believe in you I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one where it is much loved see you soon